Ireland's preparing for a vote that will
divide the country in this traditional
Catholic country abortion is still
illegal the issue has bitterly divided
Irish society for 35 years before it
will be legalized in this country very
soon although later referendums eased
the loss slightly a near total ban on
abortion remains in place in 2012
Savita halep on Evert died of
complications during pregnancy she had
requested an abortion but was refused
her death reignited the debate a new
referendum will be held on May the 25th
to polarized camps are now competing for
votes
pro-choice supporters who favor a more
liberal secular Ireland this is a hugely
important time for Ireland to look at
what we are about really as a country
and how we value in people's lives and
pro-life supporters who want to
safeguard conservative legislation this
is a very definitive referendum is one
which will decide whether Ireland keeps
its culture I already have a massive
shift in its cultural and abortion
Ireland is voting on the 8th amendment
to its constitution in which the state
acknowledges the right to life of the
unborn and with due regard to the equal
right to life of the mother
it's one of Europe's most restrictive
abortion laws banning terminations in
all circumstances except when a mother's
life is at risk the 8th amendment was
introduced in 1983 after 67% of Irish
voters supported it in a referendum
backed by the Catholic Church Alva Smith
is a veteran pro-choice activist she
campaigned against the introduction of
the Eighth Amendment in 1983 and has
fought for the liberalisation of
Ireland's abortion laws ever since 1983
was a much more brutal and violent
campaign Ireland was truly a different
country than the country I grew up in
was much more oppressive it was much
more judgmental we were regularly called
baby killers murderers yet amendment was
really the thorn in the flesh of my own
adult life the Catholic Church opposes
abortion but its influence in Ireland
has waned in recent years a series of
sexual abuse and other scandals has led
many to question the church's moral
authority since the early 1990s the
number of church attending Catholics has
fallen and attitudes have liberalized in
2015 almost two-thirds of Irish voters
endorsed a referendum proposal to
legalize same-sex marriage but the issue
of abortion remains divisive the
referendum on May the 25th will be
closed polls show the support to repeal
the Eighth Amendment stands at around
50% Navy Vereen has campaigned to retain
the Eighth Amendment and Ireland's ban
on abortion since the early 1990s the
8th amendment protects the right to life
of unborn children if you take it away
if you take it away over the
Constitution the people will never get
to vote on our abortion laws again in
this referendum campaign the church has
taken a back seat instead pro-life
groups presenting themselves as
nondenominational
are leading the church to retain the
current law I think there are probably
three key points to the debate the first
one is that abortion kills a baby and
the other
for that course absolution overwhelming
the second I think is the evidence that
shows that abortion hurts women is it
very often women are coerced into having
abortions and that it leaves them with
deep sadness and regret I think the
third point is that people understand
that if we want to have a pro-life
culture in this country and we need to
save the Eighth Amendment but pro-choice
campaigners argue that the Eighth
Amendment does not reduce the number of
abortions each year over 3,500 women
travel from Ireland to Britain for a
termination and it's estimated that up
to 2000 women purchase abortion pills
online three and a half thousand women
going to Britain for an abortion every
year makes me feel very wretched and
deeply a very profound level ashamed
that you know I'm live a part of a
society which says actually we don't
really care what happens to women
Ireland's ruling party is allowing its
politicians a free vote on the issue
Prime Minister Lee / adkar is backing
repeal and has gone one step further
proposing the right to a termination up
to the 12th week of pregnancy if the
referendum passes we already have
abortion in Ireland but it's unsafe
unregulated and unlawful and in my
opinion we kind of continue to export
our problems they're saying that you can
have abortion on demand for the first
three months of pregnancy
so that's abortion for any reason at all
or no reason and I think this is
something an extraordinary change for
Irish culture because we've
traditionally had a culture which
protected the mother and the baby this
is a kind of myth out there that you
wake up some morning and say I'm going
to have an abortion here does this come
from it comes from a fundamental
disrespect for women it's a denial of
women's right to be fully functioning
citizens and members of the state I
would never ever second-guess the people
of Ireland in a referendum I hope we can
win I believe we can win
run confirm that I'm going to vote and
in a progressive and compassionate way
to save the eighth amendment the vote to
repeal the 35 year law will determine
whether Ireland continues on its journey
to becoming a more secular society
[Applause]
you